Chabrol hchcock même combat on connaît
la passion de Claude Chabrol pour le
maître anglais du suspense ça n'a jamais
été aussi vrai que dans son tout dernier
film masque où l'on retrouve Philippe
Noiret dans le rôle d'une franche
crapule Philippe Noiret qui est sur le
plateau c'est un peu l'histoire d'un
homme ah vous êtes très antipathique et
très et très des Magos oui oui euh oui
ben c'est c'est une histoire de c'est un
film c'est une sorte de fable sur
l'hypocrisie quoi sur les masques comme
le comme le titre l'indique pour une
fois le titre un rapport avec l'histoire
et tous les personnages de ce film que
ce soit Christian leg gagneur animateur
de télévision que je joue ou euh le rôle
que joue Robin Renucci qui est celui
d'un journaliste qui vient écrire la
biographie de ce cet animateur c'est le
finer un peu contre le faocul on peut
dire oui c'est ça oui ce sont c'est un
des variations sur un thème connu
c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui a une image
qui vit dans une maison entourée des
siens et cetera et puis un corps
étranger arrive là-dedans mène sa petit
enquête sous un prétexte fallacieux
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'il n'est
pas aussi blanc bleu qu'il veut nous
nous le faire croire au début c'est un
espèce de match de partie d'échec entre
entre entre grands hypocrites quoi et
vous voulez absolument dans ce film être
sympathique le gagneur veut être
sympathique on va le voir tout de suite
dans un très court extrait on vous
trouve à table une situation que vous
aimez bien en
généralarde pas mais enfin j'aime bien
enin de présenter l'essentiel des
personnages on VO ça dans une petite
seconde
bon
bon très bon on
va ah oui ah oui beau corps belle robe
long bouge oui maîtrise toire ah faut
Tavouer qu'il est excellent
ou il est bien
ah de prison hein j'espère que vous
aimez le givier la chasse est ouverte ça
ce sont les petits secrets de Max mieux
vaut ne pas approfondir comment le
trouvez-vous avec sa toque il est beau
non il adore changer de casquette
n'est-ce pas max et Colette qui est la
meilleur secrétaire que j'ai jamais eu
mais son petit habilier blanc et ser
àable ça vous étonne ça mon cher Wolf il
faut reconnaître que ce n'est pas banal
non ce n'est pas banal c'est pour ça
qu'ils le font parce qu'il s'amuse
n'est-ce pas Colette absolument monsieur
c'est très amusant d'avoir plusieurs
vies en même temps vous avez
effectivement plusieurs vies en même
temps vous êtes un tyran domestique et
pu vous êtes un un très grand animateur
de télévision animateur producteur c'est
ça qui qui vous a inspirer parce queon
on pense à beaucoup de monde quand on
vous voit oui oui oui c'est la question
qui ne manque pas de mêtre posé
oui non personne ne m'inspira c'est
c'est la télévision et ces jeux ces
émissions de jeux qui ont inspiré les
scénaristes et puis moi bien sûr mais je
il n'y a pas personne n'est visé
directement c'est c'est une métaphore
qui englobe tout le système de de ce
genre d'émission dans ce film moi je
trouve que vous parlez très fort comme
si vous étiez à la télévision vous
l'avez prévu vous l'avez joué ou c'était
oui j'ai j'ai j'ai pensé à un type oui
effectivement qu'il y a le verbe haut et
cetera qui qui aime bien parce que comme
tout le monde rampe un peu autour de lui
il jouit de cette autorité il en profite
il en abuse un peu oui mais ce qui
permet à certains moment de passer dans
la confidence alors on sait que vous
aimez bien les bonnes choses vous êtes
un un épicurien comme on dit Chabrol
aussi et on dit que sur le tournage ça
s'est très bien passé par exemple dans
l'extrait qu'on a vu le vin c'était du
vin c'était du closou oui c'était du
closouot OUI OUI du vrai oui oui oui ça
aide ça aide nous sommes habitués à
tricher à truquer à à jouer mais enfin
quand on a une un petit plus comme ça il
suffit de se laisser aller dans la
sincérité pour une fois vous êtes vous
me disiez tout à l'heure avant le
journal un acteur de composition vous
aimez bien qu'on vous dis ce qu'il y a à
faire vous voulez pas trop susciter
vous-même la situation non j'ai essayé
une fois ou deux mais je crois que c'est
plus intéressant de faire des choses que
les gens ont envie de vous voir faire
plutôt que de faire des choses qu'on a
envie de faire soi-même ça m'amuse plus
de de de voir quand j'ouvre un scénario
je me dis qu'est-ce qu'ils ont concoé à
quoi ont-ils pensé qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent me voir faire et ça ça ça
m'excite plus que de moi de de de lire
un roman de me dire tiens c'est un
personnage pour moi et tout ça j'aime
mieux passer par le regard et et
l'intelligence et le talent des aut et
vous aimez bien l'idée d'être
présentateur dans ce film ça vous plaît
bien j'ai l'impression c'est pas la
première fois oui oui oui c'est amusant
ben j'étais journaliste deux ou trois
fois mais jamais à la télévision et vous
auriez aimé présenter faire un
présenteur de journal par exemple ah un
journal oui oui journal télévisé j'
j'aime assez surtout le vôtre parce
que je vais vous balancer quelques
compliments le journal d'Antenne 2 est
mon journal favori j'aime beaucoup la
façon dont vous présentez les actualités
votre amis Clion et vous-même je sais
que votre fauteuil est très envié à
l'heure actuelle mais à mon avis
j'aimerais beaucoup vous y voir encore
demeurer quelques très gentil mais
puisque vous invite de faire le métier
vousle prenez ma place çasz allez-y vous
allez terminer ce journal je vais faire
quelques ans vous allez terminer ce
journal alors là maintenant en principe
au conducteur vous êtes censé lancer
come on dit le rembousser pour la météo
bon maintenant il nous reste plus qu'à
écouter la météo que va vous dire avec
mon talent habituel notre ami Laurent
Boussier à vous Laurent avec un titre
qui va vous plaire puisque c'est un
titre de film demain nous jouerons qu
des brumes et nous Jons que des brumes
évidemment absolument nous Jons que des
brumes parce que demain matin une fois
de plus la visibilité va être
relativement réduite à cause des brumes
et du brouillard cela dit les choses je
prend l'avion demain matin à 9h ça ira
vous vous allez où à Rome ah bah écoutez
là-bas il fait beau de toute façon oui
mais le décollage je parle pas de
problème pour le décollage j'en étais où
oui on regarde maintenant l'image
satellite et on voit deux choses la
première c'est qu'il y a une dépression
qui est sur près des pays scandinaves
juste en bas de la Suède et de la
Norvège et puis une perturbation alors
cette perturbation était aujourd'hui sur
toute la moitié nord du pays et petit à
petit elle va passer sur la moitié sud
on la retrouve demain sur la carte du
temps prévu pour demain on la retrouve
des Pyrénées aux Alpes alors on regarde
maintenant la carte du temps prévu pour
demain des des Alpes au Massif Central
et au Pyréné le ciel restera très
nuageux couvert dans la dans la journée
avec des brumes et quelques
précipitations peut-être même quelques
PE petit flocon de neige au-dessus de
1500 m sur les Alpes le matin sur la
moitié nord donc un ciel brumeux mais
nous aurons droit à de belles éclaircis
dans la journée et puis sur la Provence
sur la Côte d'Azur et sur la Corse un
beau temps relativement ensoleillé avec
quand même quelques petits nuages
résiduels on passe maintenant aux
températures température en hausse en
hausse surtout sur le nord-est
puisqueaujourd'hui il a fait 2 3°grés du
côté de l'Alsace et de la Lorine demain
6 7°gr 7°gr aussi à Paris 10°grés à
Cherbourg et 12°g à Brest pour la moitié
nord des températures de 6 à 7°gr dans
le centre 6 à Lyon mais de 12 à 13° sur
la Côte d'Azur 11 degr à bieritz 13
degrés à perpignon et à Nice et puis
14°gr et ça ce sera uniquement en Corse
vous savez qu'on finit par l'agenda oui
je
sais temps d'apprendre ça mtié
formidable quand Mme oui oui donc on va
terminer par l'agenda demain sera donc
le samedi 7 février le soleil se lèvera
à 8h14 se couchera à 17h56 4 minutes de
soleil en plus pour ceux qui onurt la
chance de le voir et nous fêtront les
Eugénies alors voilà Philippe no il est
20h28 30 secondes maintenant il faut
dire au revoir donne le dernier
rendez-vous ce sera Philippe c'est 22h50
écoutez oui merci de nous avoir écouté
jusqu'ici le dernier journal vous sera
présenté par Philippe aroir aux environs
de
22h50 merci mon cher
bernardité oui mais écoutez vous revenez
quand vous voulez merci donc on se
retrouve en tout cas sans Philippe
Noiret demain hélas à 20h précise
premier rendez-vous demain c'est à 13h
pour pour samedi chez vous Noël ma mère
[Musique]
bonsoir